hey guys Ryan Wright here and today I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles heroes in a half shell
turtle power
I got like this really red eye right now
and it's totally bothering me I am so
[ __ ] excited to watch this damn
trailer I woke up this morning and like
every single video I've ever posted
someone or should I say a lot of [ __ ]
people was telling me the new trailers
out for the new movie then something
kind of hit me like I haven't done any
shoutouts to some subscribers in a while
you know and there's like so many of you
that I interact with on a daily basis
that you know I feel like I should you
know say hi to some of you guys I'm
going off memory here so let's see okay
Noah Bennet or bidet whatever I don't
know your name dude you give some of the
best compliments ever I [ __ ] love all
the nice [ __ ] you say you touch my heart
Nathan Ross who really inflicted a
philosophy on me today telling me no you
got to do it for the fans and I was like
you know what Nathan you are right Oh a
lot of good-looking subscribers that
it's predominantly a male demographic in
the subscriber base what every once a
while a pretty good-looking female
subscribes and we got a new subscriber
guys her name is Michelle Fernandez I
have seen her thumbnail and she is fine
Michelle if you're watching this you and
I man if you live in LA she's totally
meet up man you can do one of them
trailer videos of me and then who knows
what will happen when the camera turns
off anyway back to the turtles I am
really excited to see this [ __ ]
trailer I I love the Turtles man the
first trilogy was awesome I always go
back and forth between which one's my
favorite I even like the one that took
place in Japan a hell of a lot the show
was great I even liked that animated CGI
thing that came out a few years ago that
no one seemed to like I I just love
these [ __ ] it's it's awesome and
Michael Bay's producing this most
respected filmmaker on the planet and
Meghan Fox is gonna be back you [ __ ]
like my cameras about to die I just
really had to watch this trailer and I
couldn't wait any longer I couldn't let
the battery charge oh my god it's like
I'm about to play this and ever so many
things about this film a night okay here
he goes
crime violence and fear have run rampant
they have our great city is being
destroyed
oh [ __ ] looks like transformers people
want justice restored to this farm
people want heroes oh she's so hot oh
[Music]
hell yeah it's happening they're
creative that's what your father and I
were trying to do
shredder
create heroes [ __ ] tails just a mouse
see oh my god dude that film is gonna
[ __ ] rock holy [ __ ] it's the Turtles
man the [ __ ] Ninja Turtles and they
brought together what looks like a
rather serious film that I'm sure is
gonna have plenty of humour make it Fox
like she's just perfect eye candy man I
would totally you know what I actually
wouldn't have sex with Megan Fox because
Megan is my sister's name and that kind
of creeps me out but you know whatever I
guess if I just call her Fox if we're
fooling around whatever when I saw
stills of the actors running in their
[ __ ] suits I was like this is gonna
be stupid but then looking at this the
effects look great like it's gonna be so
easy to buy this film you're gonna be
able to just be pulled in and the action
looks great all they have brought the
Ninja Turtles to life the way they were
meant to be brought in it's it's about
[ __ ] time gosh with the technology we
have now because we have advanced as
humans this is gonna be epic and if
you're new to the channel subscribe so I
got